house coronavirus task force is coming
up and there's been some encouraging
news this week one key model forecasting
far fewer deaths from coronavirus than
earlier estimates but we still need to
keep up the social distancing across the
country to keep that trend going the
media is not making the situation any
better with attacks like this on
president Trump take a look
tens of thousands of people who will die
in the country or had some hope of them
have already died more are still going
to die because of Donald Trump's
incompetence and lack of leadership here
we have a president who is exploiting a
national crisis to move forward his own
agenda his own revenge his own profit
and it gets worse
MSNBC's Chris Hayes promoting a
conspiracy theory that the Trump
administration inflated the death toll
projections so the president could take
a quote victory lap when they came in
much lower Greg I want to start with you
you always feel so strongly about the
media and I wanted to ask you is there
anything that you think the mainstream
media will have an appropriate
perspective on I think you know I
completely understand the political the
politics it's a team sport thing and
it's like a fire like some viruses it's
incurable the only thing that bothers me
is that the media is so clearly on one
side I would like to change that it's
never gonna happen
Acosta asking about whether Trump had
investments in hydroxi that wasn't as if
Trump would risk his reelection his
legacy for a couple of hundred dollars
in stock is just moronic but what's even
more moronic it's not even a Casta
original he stole that from the hack
buffet known as that dopey duo warning
Joe so I think we should start doing
contact tracing on really dumb ideas in
the media you know identify someone
who's been near somebody who's been
infected by a dumb idea and then try to
trace it back so oh it starts at MSNBC
and then the virus moves to CNN and then
moves back to MSNBC and keeps going
around and if we could stop it we could
prevent more infections but what last
point if the result if this pandemic is
that far less than what we predicted
it's gonna create a swirl of unprovable
arguments so we might as well just get
used to it we're gonna have one side
saying was all social distance
distancing another one saying the fear
was oversold the projections were
ridiculous people will say that Trump
saved lives by shutting down travel
others will say no we put a cop economy
before people these things are going to
go on for the rest of your life you
don't want to get sucked into it because
they're all almost all unprovable Dana I
wanted to play a video for you and get
your thoughts on it this is what James
Carville had to say what Republicans
will do to stay in power take a look and
then we'll get your thoughts what I do
fear up is what you had in Wisconsin
where they try to mock with the election
and stop people from birthing in
Wisconsin but one of the most awful
things I've ever seen in my life you
know just go you the extent that what
they will go to to hold on to power and
it's all about one Supreme Court seat in
Wisconsin they will kill people to stay
in power literally so you want me to
react to that so um okay it was constant
thing I think that clearly there is a
lot of criticism that could be thrown
that way I don't know well why they
couldn't have worked it out I know there
is blame to be had on both sides the
Republicans in the legislature the
governor being a Democrat slow to move
they couldn't work together I do think
the most ridiculous thing was you had
the Speaker of the House or the
leadership of the state legislature a
Republican in full-on protective gear
with a mask doing an interview telling
everybody in Wisconsin that it was
perfectly safe to go outside and vote
that I think opened them up to a lot of
criticism and it's not too early to
start thinking about what to do in the
future there are criticisms about
mail-in voting though you have a state
like Utah it's all mail-in they don't
seem to have any problem nobody
questions it we can have that debate and
this issue of voter suppression the
Democrats are going to talk about that a
lot between now and November and I think
the Republicans have to have a much
better answer as to how they're going to
try to deal with it so all of those
things are happening if I could say one
thing about the quest
that a cost opposed to the president
about the funding it reminded me of for
eight years the media would go after
Dick Cheney over and over again for
investments in Halliburton he had no
investments in Halliburton when he was
the vice president he would not be able
to benefit and it didn't matter how many
times you explained this to them in a
very logical way the media just didn't
care they just continue to try to puddle
some pummel somebody but I think if I
could use a sports analogy this one at
four hundred and fifty dollars that's
the investment that's what you would
call a swing and a Miss Jesse ABC
published a damaging report on President
Trump's reaction to this and then a
military official refuted it and they
refused to issue a correction will we
ever see some type of acknowledgment of
the responsibility that they've had in
shaping that narrative probably not you
didn't see it with Russia I don't see
why you wouldn't see it with this I mean
if we had today's media during World War
two
they would blame FDR for Pearl Harbor
instead of the Japanese they probably
blame the House Republicans at the time
but you see my point
this is China's deal China lied the
w-h-o botched this the virus mother
earth is killing people not the
president I mean there's still so much
we don't know about this virus this is
an invisible enemy we shut down the
entire US economy that wasn't aggressive
enough I mean that criticized the
president for acting too later not
listening to the scientists show me in
February where dr. Burks and fowey said
we needed all shelter in place you can't
find it because it didn't happen you
know how many deaths there were in this
country from kovat 19 on March 1st one
show me one
pundit that spoke on television for the
need to have the whole country shelter
in place if you can find that person
I'll buy him around the drinks but it
didn't happen they were obsessed with
Mike Bloomberg at this time and to
Greg's point you can play with these
models and projections however way you
want you can say Trump save lives you
could say mitigation work you could say
the models were wrong or the
models were updated when new information
was put into it look at the climate
change models all of them have been
wrong yet people are obsessed with the
climate change models I mean I could
play this game all day I could say
Barack Obama did nothing while the
opioid epidemic cost 200,000 American
lives and that's on him I could say that
but I won't because I'm a very classy
guy all right one what are your thoughts
on anything you like from what everyone
said well let me just Emily let me just
go back to this business about what
happened in Wisconsin you know I just
thought that was I just thought that was
a huge flaw I think was an embarrassment
for us as an American people I don't
think people should have to choose
between staying healthy and you know
participating in an election I thought
it was wrong and you know even when
there were questions about mailing
voting to the president yesterday the
president said oh no it's terrible if
you could see a lot of fraud and I Peter
said but mr. president you voted by mail
in the last election and Flowery said
yeah that's true
I mean to me it's just again about voter
suppression so we'll come back to that
topic as to the media well I think a lot
of what we're hearing there to me I
would put it in the category Emily of
not helping us to move forward not you
know not helping us to progress and get
out of this situation is so serious I'd
rather not get hooked up in those kind
of trivial finger-pointing backbiting
backstabbing I will say that a
nonpartisan basis the fact is that we as
a country were slow to respond in
specific the president when he was
downplaying the series of it I think the
administration was slow to respond but
let's leave it there and let's now try
to pick up pace and do the things that
are necessary to get us in the right
place because I think that we that
there's no need for us to get involved
in harsh conspiracy theories that don't
actually lead us in a more prolific in a
more productive place I just went back
one point oh he did shut down okay
travel three days after
it was raised so I I mean maybe you
could have done it the same thing I
didn't and he got it he got to anybody
clear is that there were people well
listen in fact he would send people who
work still coming in that I think this
more than a half million people still
came from China because you had
Americans coming back from that area and
you had people coming from Italy you had
people coming from Germany and from
Britain so it did it let's argue about
the effectiveness in another way I'm not
sure I'm just saying we as a country
were slow to respond and let's focus now
on what we can do because right now even
as we reopen businesses what we're going
to see is that people are slow to get
back to the restaurant slow to get back
on an airplane slow to get back to
analyze why and that's on China with
enough with the blame game it's on China